même s'ils prennent de plus en plus de
place sur nos routes et qu'ils
alourdissent la congestion toutes les
raisons sont bonnes pour les acheter
parce que j'ai trois enfants on fait du
sport et on a besoin d'une plus grosse
voiture parce qu'on voyage pas léger
bien je suis pas demain c'est pour la
traction intégrale c'est pour la
sécurité puis c'est pas pour l'économie
de s'en sortir depuis 1990 le nombre de
camions légers comme les véhicules
utilitaires sport et les camionnettes de
type pick up a pratiquement quadruplé
sur les routes canadiennes alors que le
nombre de voitures standard lui a grimpé
d'à peine 10 pour ça leur popularité est
grandissante en 2021 ces quatre
véhicules neufs vendus sur cinq qui sont
des camions légers au canada puis au
québec en fait depuis 2015 il plus de
camions légers qui se vante que deux
voitures également l'impact sur les
émissions de ges est vraiment important
en fait c'est ce qui en ce moment un
frein dans l'atteinte de nos simples
climatique depuis 1990 les émissions de
gaz à effet de serre des camions légers
ont trompé de 156% trois fois plus que
celle de l'ensemble du parc automobile
canadien qui ont augmenté de 49 pour ça
le bilan aurait été bien meilleur si les
consommateurs avaient continué à acheter
de plus petites voitures on a vraiment
raté l'occasion en gravats ces véhicules
plus efficaces énergétiquement par là et
on a finalement à courage et les gens à
acheter des véhicules plus gros en
maintenant leur niveau de consommation
énergétique ils sont de plus en plus
gros selon un rapport d'équiterre en 25
ans la hauteur des camions légers a
augmenté de 7% la surface qu'ils
occupent au sol de 11% et leurs masses
de 25 pour ça c'est donc beaucoup d
espaces perdus notamment dans le grand
montréal pendant les 20 dernières années
c'est l'équivalent de 17 parc la
fontaine des espaces qui ont été perdus
en stationnement en espace urbain être
pour freiner les ventes de camions
légers équiterre pense que la publicité
doit être encadrée pour qu'on y affiche
par exemple la consommation d'essence ou
les gs produits par ces véhicules
les constructeurs savent que
l'électrification est à nos portes mais
ils vont quand même justement faire la
promotion des plus gros véhicule puis
nrj va parce que la marge de profit plus
élevé en ce moment parmi les autres
propositions une taxe à l'achat des
subventions pour la mise au rancart y
miser davantage sur les véhicules
électriques
mais il faut tout d'abord reconnaître
que la popularité des camions légers est
un problème ici olivier cachin radio
canada montréal